if deep time is incomprehensible how
does the human brain actually understand
the deep time over which it is now
believed to have evolved so dad this is
like a tricky question right you got to
read this a couple times before you
understand what it means but basically
Darwin asks us to imagine that human
beings along with other animals and
plants emerged over deep time that over
millions and millions of years human
beings changed from essentially apes and
monkeys into the people that we have
today
the human brain is therefore not just a
product of evolution but it is a product
of deep time how does the brain
understand the deep time over which it
is believed to have evolved so this also
requires conceptualization people had
been thinking about the brain for
several hundred years this is an example
of how you can look at different kinds
of brains over the course of the 18th
century so comparing brains thinking
about brains this idea is not new but
what you have in the 19th century is the
first effort to understand the human
brain in geological terms as the product
of deep time so the imagine that there's
a lower part of the brain that is very
very primitive and it can only
understand space in terms of time that
is it takes me three days to walk to
Menlo Park that is how far Menlo Park is
from here it takes me three days to walk
there
that's the primitive part of the brain
they think in the 19th century over time
the higher parts of the brain like
geological strata accreting begin to get
deposited in the human mind leading to
our modern advanced brains how do we
know they're modern and advanced is that
we can imagine time in terms of space we
have things like clocks that help us to
see time in spatial terms
this is a sign of how advanced we are so
the human brain begins to be imagined
like a geological stratum in the 19th
century that it's strata like rocks are
layered through time now let me show you
how that idea has crept into our way of
thinking and talking today in ways that
we didn't even know many of us all of
you in this room have certainly used the
term the stream of consciousness and you
have probably used it without
understanding the origins of this term
well it emerges from the deep time
revolution in the writing of the Harvard
psychologist William James who studied
with the geologist Louis Agassiz at
Harvard and was very very influenced by
this new deep time way of thinking not
just about the earth as layered strata
but about the human brain as layered
strata so he tried to explain how you
could understand the flow of human
thought as a kind of geological process
so he asks you to imagine saying this
sentence the pack of cards is on the
table this is gonna bring back traumatic
memories of diagramming sentences in
seventh grade so I'm sorry
because it brought those back for me
sorry mrs. collie I didn't like
diagramming sentences but William James
is asking us to imagine and I actually I
brought a prop so here look at this the
pack of cards is on the table and he's
asking you to diagram what the brain is
doing as it is thinking that thought so
and he calls this the stream of
consciousness so here's what he's
imagining remember the XY axis I showed
you earlier in the talk this is exactly
what he's doing he's imagining you
saying this sentence the pack of cards
is on the table and the 1 2 3 & 4 is not
grammatical right it's just like time
time is happening one two three four and
then he has this y-axis this spatial
dimension and what the space is it's not
a kind of geological stratum but it is
what he calls the fullness of thought so
as you're saying the sentence and as
you're thinking it your mind is getting
fuller and fuller and fuller of the
thought of the pack of cards being on
the table so that at the end of the
sentence you're way up high with your
thinking about the pack of cards being
on the table now what's interesting
about this is that he says if you put a
knife through the center of the thought
imagine doing that put a knife through
the center of the thought you would find
it suffused with the whole of all of the
rest of the thought just like a knife
cutting through the strata of the rocks
that I have been showing you would show
you cutting through all of the strata of
the earth so when you use the term the
stream of consciousness he means a
stream in the literal geological sense
of the term that our brains have
thoughts running through them that are
like streams that erode through our
minds and that we can diagram them like
a geological strata
[Music]